there was no break in between three and
four I went straight to Turtles and I
shot at the entirety of the break and in
between four and five I promoted Turtles
and then in between five and six I want
to wait for a little bit but then we
shot all of code eight and in between
six and seven I went away like on this
beautiful trip but then come came back
and shot code eight and went right back
to work and there's just no break just
no brain you're not taking care of
yourself I mean take a break I'm just
not taking a break and a break
I think stopping working out was a real
big contributing factor because there's
got to be if there's gonna be a yin
there's got to be a yang